l' enthousiasme pour la co réanime le
centre-ville de montréal
ce kiosque de restauration rapide
prolonge ses heures d'ouverture les
soirs de match tout le monde de la
nourriture tout mode amical puis ça
passe vite ses soeurs comme ça et à
l'état c'est un final c'est la folie
l'affluence dans cet hôtel du
centre-ville est à son plus haut depuis
le début de la pandémie et on sera
complet nous ce vendredi pour le premier
match à domicile
l'hôtel opère environ la moitié de ses
capacités presque vide
avec environ 200 chambres à louer tout
son charme losc ont vendu ce qui est
quand même une première depuis je
voudrais peut-être 14 15 mois c'est un
moment absolument magique il remarque
lui aussi une hausse de réservations de
dernière minute en provenance de
plusieurs régions au québec
même des gens du lac saint jean ont
conduit des allers-retours domine seule
nuit puis ça nous a aidé le carnet se
remplit plus l'engouement pour la finale
de la coupe stanley profite aux
hôteliers comme aux restaurateurs
c'est ce que quand on est porté à
lisbourg la game est soit d'un bord d'un
resto as acheté plus de consommation
allez vous regarder le match de demain
ce dernière des hameaux
chez nous il ya un énorme impact qui
soirs de matchs de hockey autant dans
nos salles à manger une hausse non
ceinture mais aussi d'un niveau du
raison et pour ceux qui voudraient
assister en personne au duel avec le
lightning des billets se revendaient des
prix astronomiques en ligne jusqu'à 35
mille dollars pour une paire s'il n'y
avait pas des milliers de dollars à
dépenser
il sera peut-être possible de regarder
les matchs dans les parcs à montréal la
ville est en discussions avec le groupe
ch
les autorités de santé publique et le
spvm dit sylvie lefebvre radio-canada à
montréal